Placing markers as we're knitting can
be a real help to keep track of things
as we're knitting along when you're
seaming long pieces or the side seams
of sweaters, for example, it's helpful
to have markers at regular intervals on
both the front and the back side seams.
This can make it a lot easier
to precisely join the seam.
The most common use of markers is
when knitting a drop shoulder sweater.
It's really helpful to have a marker
at the start of the armhole opening.
So when it comes time to join
the sleeves, you'll know exactly
where they should be positioned.
You use DesignaKnit, Original Pattern
Drafting and add markers as you create
your garment pieces, and the markers
will be included in some of the outputs.
Interactive knitting, garment outline and
garment notation formats include markers.
Let's practice this in
Standard Garment Syling.
We'll create a simple drop shoulder
or a straight sleeve style.
I'll just go through and
accept all the defaults.
We want to get some pieces on the screen.
Then switched to Original Pattern Drafting
and we'll start playing with markers.
Select the front piece and zoom in.
There are two ways to set markers.
You can use the menu item,
>technique, >set marker.
Look!
DesignaKnit is smart enough to recognize
this as a drop shoulder sweater and
it automatically places markers at the
underarm points where we want them.
Now another way to turn on
markers is to use the marker tool.
You can use either one of these
methods to turn the display on and
off, but once the marker is set,
you don't have to display them.
They'll be remembered.
Let's add a marker halfway through
the side seam of our front.
If you turn on the marker tool and click
and click and click, nothing happens.
Markers are assigned to points.
Use the plus or the add tool.
Since I have mirroring on
appoint will be positioned on
each side of the front piece.
I can now turn a marker
on those two points.
To use these points with printable
instructions, click >file and
>print, choose garment outline.
Then click the single wrench button
and make sure that the checkbox
"include markers" is checked.
When you print or preview the
outline, the markers will be included.
This is helpful if you
use these for blocking.
Let's look at garment notation.
Choose garment notation, click on
that single wrench and click the
"include markers" check box again.
This time when you print or preview the
row numbers of the markers are included
with the Japanese notation instructions.
Finally, when using interactive knitting.
You'll be alerted when to place markers.
set marker.
Please take time to learn
this really helpful feature of
DesignaKnit and Happy Knitting!.